♪ ♪ ♪
- Les photographies de presse
gagnantes du prestigieux World
Press Photo sont une fenêtre
unique sur le monde. Et c'est
ce qui a poussé Caroline Monnet
à devenir la porte-parole
de l'édition 2022 présentée
à Montréal.
CAROLINE MONNET, artiste
multidisc. et porte-parole
- C'est très fort, cette année,
les propositions
photographiques. Toutes les
photos ici, c'est un peu comme
le pouls de ce qui se passe
à travers le monde. Il y a
des photos, comme à ma droite,
une photo qui montre la guerre
en Ukraine. C'est simplement
une statue, un monument qui est
décapité, mais je trouve que
l'image, elle parle d'elle-mme.
- En plus de la guerre
en Ukraine, il est aussi
question de conflits en Afrique,
de déforestation en Amérique
du Sud et d'incendies i i ont
ravagé la planète.
Le grand prix annuel a été remis
à une Canadienne, Amber Bracken,
dont cette photographie a été
publiée dans le "N Y York
Times". Il s'agit de croix
en bois installées pour
commémorer la disparation
de tous ces enfants décédés
au pensionnaauautochtone
de Kamloops.
Cette photographie et toutes
celles mettant en lumière
les préoccupations de peuples
autochtones ont ému
Caroline Monnet.
- C'est une image qui me touche
profondément. Des sujets qui
sont en plein dans l'actualité
de la dernière année, puis...
parce que ça touche toutes
s s questions autochtones,
donc j'ai trouvé que d'accepter
ce rôle-là cette année,
c'était doublement symbolique.
- En plus des images gagnantes
du World Press Photo 2022,
l'édition montréalaise présente
une exposition de l'équipe des
"Décrypteurs" de Radio-Canada
sur les fausses nouvelles.
Il y a aussi une série
baptisée "Claire, 107 ans",
une incursion dans le quotidien
d'une centenaire, captée
par l'artiste ststine Latour.
JUSTINE LATOUR, photographe,
"Claire, 107 ans"
- Elle est pleine de mystère
encore, aiaire. Moi, je n'ai pas
tout élucidé. Et je... C'est
peut-être ça, en fait, ma quête
photographique, c'est tout
leememps d'aller un peu
au bout de cette femme-là.
Mais je pense qu'elle va
emporter bien des secrets.
- - Émouvante et essentielle,
l'exposition World Press Photo
Montréal est présentée
au Marché Bonsecours
jusqu'au 2 octobre prochain.
Ici Louis-Philippe